يقدر بستة وثلاثين مليار دولار
والذي استولت عليه عائلة واحدة
في مدينة الخليل للمستوطنين
مقابل عشرين مليون دولار وتقول
لتصبح في الرابع عشر من مايو
المقبل. هذا الرئيس الذي يحكم
لزيادة نفوذها في منطقة المحيط
الهادئ والذي لم يعد هادئا بعد
استراليا اعتزامها تسريع خطط
شراء الغام البحرية متطورة
انهم عرضوا عليها ان تعيش في
اوروبا او امريكا مع عائلتها
فلتتعل هذا الدرس منها يا جحافل
التطبيع. اجتمع الغرب مرة اخرى
ستضمن استمرار الوضع الجيد
للولايات المتحدة لتوفير موقف
الاقل وذلك بحسب صحيفة نيويورك
تايمز الامريكية. ويقول
بالقرب من البحر الاسود في
اوكرانيا وهذا تعزيز قوي للبحرية
منظومة الروسية للدفاع الجوي
للمرة الاولى على اسطح بنايات
ومسيرة كبرى بالعاصمة اليمنية
صنعاء تنديدا باحراق نسخة من
سقوط قتلى في قصف على محافظة
صعدة متهمة التحالف بينما نفت
المصحف في السويد فيا له من
طوفان بشري. اعلنت جماعة الحوثي
الرياض مسؤوليتها عن الحادث.
سيدة فلسطينية ترفض بيع منزلها
السياسية والتجارية والاقتصادية
بينما يتصدر ملف امدادات الغاز
لمحاربة الفساد والفاسدين. تزور
رئيسة الوزراء الايطالي جورجيا
ميلوني الجزائر لاول مرة منذ
توليها السلطة لبحث الشراكة
ميلوني بغاز الجزائر ام تعود
حاملة خفي حنين كمن سبقوها?
الجزائري على رأس قائمة الطلبات
الايطالية فهل تعود جورجيا
وفق تصريح الرئيس عبدالمجيد
تبون. هناك وعد تبون بالاستقرار
الاهم للخطوة القادمة وماذا عن
حرق القرآن الكريم يا هذا?
عن ارسال ملك البحر ليخرج وزير
الدفاع الاوكراني مصرحا ان
على دبابات متطورة مما دفعها
للبحث عن حل اخر فاعلنت تشكيل
الدموي. ومن الدعم البري الى
الكرم البحري. هنا بريطانيا تعلن
تزويد كييف بالاسلحة. لان ذلك
سيؤدي الى صراع عالمي طويل الامد
منذ عشرين عاما ويأمل البقاء
بمنصبه لخمسة اعوام اضافية وهي
استطلاع لشبكة سي ان ان
الامريكية يظهر ان غالبية
من نهايته. هنا متظاهرون غاضبون
يحاصرون قنصلية السويد في
النفاق السياسي لا يدوم طويلا.
والتقرب السويدي للاتراك يقترب
قدم اردوجان الانتخابات الرئاسية
والتشريعية في تركيا عن موعدها
اسطنبول ويقومون باحراق علم
السويد منادين بقطع العلاقات
الاحداث والتطورات. عثرت السلطات
في الجزائر على مبلغ مالي كبير
فيبدو انه مشغول بامر اخر اكثر
اهمية من السويد بالنسبة له. حيث
لهم العم سام بامتلاك هذا
السلاح. تركيا تصفع السويد.
محادثات بشأن استخدام اصول البنك
المركزي الروسي المصادرة والتي
لتخرج من بين الرماد وتحت كل تلك
الضغوطات. دولة عربية اتخذت قرار
اليوم. ومن استراليا الى كوريا
الجنوبية. والتي تملكها الخوف
القوات البحرية الصينية وجنوب
افريقيا. خلال ذلك اعلنت
ولم تجد وسيلة لحماية نفسها بعد
ان اهتزت ثقتها بحلفائها وفي
لحماية طرقها البحرية من اي
معتدين محتملين. وسط خطط الصين
المسماة بفرقاطة بوتين المسلحة
الزركون والتي تفوق سرعتها سرعة
مشاركة الفرقاطة امران اسطول
الاتحاد السوفيتي جورشكوف
الامريكي. وبعد بضعة اشهر على
ارسالهم الى رومانيا قررت امريكا
رادع قوي ودفاعي الى جانب
حلفائها في اوروبا. صراعات
الحلفاء. حروب الحلفاء تشتعل وكل
يبحث عن حلفائه لتجد الصين نفسها
موسكو لتعلن بعدها الدفاع
الروسية عن اطلاق تدريبات خاصة
مشبها ذلك باطفاء الحريق
بالبنزين لكن لا دبابات وصلت
تقدر بقيمة ثلاثمائة مليار دولار
لاعادة اعمار اوكرانيا. ياتي
اوكرانيا بالسلاح. حيث سلم حوالي
عشرين دبابة الى كييف قبل اسبوع
توسيع عملياتها خارج اوكرانيا.
ليعتبر البنتاجون ان هذه الخطوة
المسؤولون الامريكيون ان بقاء
الفرقة مائة وواحد بالقرب من
تمديد انتشار الاف من القوات
الامريكية لتسعة اشهر اضافية على
يبد اي تصريح بهذا الخصوص الى
هذه اللحظة. وفي الجانب
والجميع يفتح خزائنه العسكرية
ليكرم اوكرانيا. برأيكم هل
انضمام السويد لحلف الناتو. اما
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوجان
امريكية ستصل كييف سيتم سحقها.
لتضع واشنطن على اذنيها القليل
معظمها في امريكا الجنوبية
كالارجنتين والبرازيل وكولومبيا.
باسلحة هجومية سيؤدي الى كارثة
عالمية محذرا الدول الغربية من
ان بلادها مستعدة للسماح لبولندا
بارسال دبابات ليوبارد
الاوكرانية بحسب تعبيره. وتنوعت
المساعدات العسكرية لاوكرانيا
اوكرانيا حتى الان لتتولد بسبب
ذلك خيبة امل اوكرانية للحصول
المغرب حيث افاد موقع ان المغرب
اصبح اول دولة افريقية تزود
بعد تحديثها في جمهورية تشيك.
الاتحاد الاوروبي بدوره لم يقف
الدبلوماسية مع ستوكهولم
ومطالبين حكومتهم بتفعيل لعدم
لحمايته من التنين الصيني ومن
زعيم كوريا الشمالية فهل سيسمح
الكوريين الجنوبيين يؤيدون
امتلاك بلادهم للسلاح النووي.
اسلحة الى اوكرانيا خلال قمة
الالماني. نعم يا سادة. انها
الصوت وسيتم اطلاقها في مناورات
مشتركة في فبراير القادم مع
بجانب الحليف الاقوى. نعم يا
سادة انه بوتين ليتم الاعلان عن
الحدود الاوكرانية ياتي للسماح
لها بالتدخل في حال قررت روسيا
في الازمة الاوكرانية يعد من
اخطر التوجهات مؤكدة ان اي اسلحة
الخارجية الروسية بقولها ان
روسيا اعلنت مرارا ان اي تصعيد
انه ستكون هناك اجراءات انتقامية
وباسلحة احدث واقوى. ليعزز ذلك
وتردد. ها هي وزيرة الخارجية
الالمانية انالينا بيربوك تعلن
البلطيق الثلاث تستجيب للرئيس
الاوكراني وتتجاهل تحذيرات موسكو
الاوكرانية ليستنجد زلينسكي
بالغرب. فهل ينقذونه? هنا دول
ومكثفة لوحدات الدفاع الجوي في
مقاطعة موسكو ولكن الكرملين لم
لتتسلل رائحة الخوف والحرص الى
موسكو. والتي بدورها قامت بنشر
طائرات قد وصلت من المملكة
المتحدة الى مملكتها الجديدة
للولايات المتحدة ان امريكا تعمل
مع الدول التي لديها معدات روسية
من متجاهلة تهديدات الروس. حيث
قال قائد القيادة الجنوبية
تصريح المتحدث الروسي بسكوف ان
الشعب الاوكراني سيدفع ثمن امداد
الرد من بلغاريا حيث دعا الرئيس
البلغاري رومان راديف الى وقف
وحدات عسكرية جديدة للتدرب على
اسلحة الناتو لتستعد للربيع
واردوغان يقدم موعد الانتخابات.
والجزائر تنعش خزينتها بستة
انتظار. خرج رئيس مجلس الدوما
الروسي قائلا ان تزويد اوكرانيا
وتلاتين مليار دولار. بينما
رئيسة وزراء ايطاليا تترك
غضبها متهمة المانيا بالتهرب عن
دعم كييف وموجهة دعوة للدول لدعم
للطاقة وطوفان بشري من اليمن
يحمل رسالة نارية للسويد.
اما للتبرع بها او تبديلها
بمعدات امريكية وتلك الدول
وحث رئيسه شارل ميشيل زعماء دول
الاوروبي على المضي قدما في
الاسلحة الى كييف تتحمل
المسئولية ليأتي الرد الاوضح من
كييف الالمانية عبر دول اخرى.
مشيرا الى ان الدول التي تضخ
لاوكرانيا. فهل يخاطر الالمان
بمواجهة الروسي فورا ودون
موسكو على الارض بضربات وقصف
مكثف وسيطرة على الاراضي
تصريح روسي شديد اللهجة. غضب
الروس في اوكرانيا ترجمته قوات
القوات الامريكية تتسكع في
الحدود الروسية وجنرال البحار
فهل يكون هو الهدف القادم لروسيا
بعد اوكرانيا والدبابات
اوكرانيا بالاسلحة الحديثة ليأتي
رد برلين اخيرا وبعد جدل كبير
مطالبة برلين بتزويد كييف
بدبابات بين اعلنت بولندا عن
البارفان الفرنسي وتتعطر بالغاز
الجزائري. فهل تشبع جوع روما
الاتراك غاضبون من السويد. فهل
يتم رفض انضمامها للناتو?
يصل لنجدة القوات الاوكرانية
وبوتين يحرك وحش المحيط للرد.
اعلنها الروس والمغرب يقف في وجه
بوتين ويتورط في حرب اوكرانيا.
الالمانية تتجه نحو اوكرانيا
وموسكو تحضر للرد كما وعدت ان
سيستمر هذا الدعم
امريكية ستصل كييف سنسحقها
وسيؤدي ذلك لكارثة عالمية. هكذا